alright i'll support AV work from once
in my life cool uh so welcome everybody
i'm going to be talking about a lot of
basically the methodologies and
practices that we do a bit ly to move
quickly without breaking the internet
because not rail mount of that goes
through our servers so before i get into
the meat of that let me get something
another way that tends to come up with
bit ly so just out of curiosity how many
people here where at least bit ly in the
form of like short links right awesome
cool a lot of times that gets me just
like really seriously how is that a
company right like i can literally write
a URL shortener before I'm you're done
with this talk how is that a thing it's
child's play come on and even then how
do you make money off their like even if
I grant that like doing this with high
availability and doing in a large scale
is difficult like how do you possibly
come on e off for short links well short
answer is branding so we have tools for
basically having companies hosts there
are only URL shorteners to Russ as so
you can see there ESPN links those r us
and analytics so every click that goes
through bit ly we do a bunch of tracking
and we do much number crunching to keep
track of what's going on so let's talk
from a technical perspective about what
actually kind of challenges we're
dealing with so every single day we see
200 million redirects 20 million
shortens we crawl about four million
pages on the web just to roll that up
for some people that works out to about
six billion klicks a month we do that
with about 400 servers spread across two
data centers with 25 engineers doing
20-plus deploys every day right so
that's a lot of change going out all the
time so let's get into kind of how we
think about that and how we do
and some of the challenges involved
right so when you talk about doing
something like 20 deploys every day
there's a tension that's going on there
right on one hand you want to be keeping
things safe right if those short links
that we have all over the web but at
this point there are literally tens of
billions of bit ly links and it's
embedded throughout the web right so if
those break nobody's happy right like
that's a really bad day people are
pissed off right it's it's really no
good I've been there when we have had
outages it's it's bad the flip side is
we need to ship things quickly right hey
just like the end of they be frank where
a VC back start-up right either we grow
and learn or die that's just how the
business works we have competitors and
we have stuff we want to ourselves and
let our customers want so we have to
keep shipping stuff so at least these
really conflicting desires could a lot
of weight a lot of things you do to move
quickly it has to break stuff right like
the the classic facebook like move fast
and break right like that's that's
a problem for us so this is going to be
talking about basically it's just going
to be kind of like a shotgun of stuff
that we do to deal with that and at the
top of the list is automation we
automate everything and a lot of it is
just because if we didn't we would break
down crying there's just no way this
stuff can work without it so of those
400 server as i mentioned 200 of those
are in AC 2 and at that scale we get an
email at least once a week saying hey
your servers going to go away in a few
weeks and then there's probably another
one or two that just go away without any
warning right like that's a thing that
we have to deal with if we were manually
replacing and provisioning those servers
we would need an army of sisson minutes
which isn't practical both its terms of
like salaries that we can pay as well as
just like a thing to manage right like
that's just nuts another part of why we
automate everything is just computers
are faster right a lot of day at the end
of the day a lot of what traditional
system ins do is fairly kind of wrote
chemical work right like ninety percent
of provisioning a server is just doing
the same things over and over and over
again and not messing up computers are a
lot better at doing that and doing it
quickly right so it's example right now
for us and we haven't actually spent a
whole lot of time optimizing this for us
to go for making the API requests to
provision an AC to server to something
live handling production data is about
10 minutes if somebody were to do all
the work that happens in that process
manually you're talking about at least a
day of somebody being completely focused
on that work and they probably are going
to mess something up in that process
which kind of guess in the next part why
we really like automation is computers
are a lot more consistent than humans
right they have limitations as far as
like pattern recognition and flexibility
but if you give them the same inputs in
the same environment to work in it's
really really likely that they're going
to do exactly what they did yesterday
today right so that Jeremy is a nice
attribute and that I can trust to the
script that I did ran yesterday is going
to wear the same today but that gets
really powerful when you have a solid
review and testing process in place
right so there's a certain amount that i
can do reviewing testing with humans but
since they're fuzzy and they're not
going to perfectly duplicate things
every time just because somebody
deployed something yesterday i'm not
going to be super confident that they're
going to get it perfect today on the
other hand if i have a script that went
through a review process and worked in
dev and worked in staging and worked in
production yesterday I'm super confident
that assuming the environment has a
change it's going to work exactly the
same today which can be really powerful
for basically getting stuff done quickly
and then taking things beyond deployment
we really take automation throughout
everything so this is Jenkins for us we
actually have a bit like a little
process so I don't get into we use
github pull requests for basically all
of our code review so anytime code gets
pushed to an open pull request the
Jenkins Jenkins will run
our automated tests against that code
it's one of those things that makes it
makes a lot of information available to
people very quickly that otherwise would
take a lot more time additionally
operational tasks pretty much any time
you know the first time we might do we
do a particular operational tasks like
let's say I don't know expanding the
resources available to a database or
something we might do that manually by
the second time we do it we automate it
because at that point it's very likely
there'll be a third time in a fourth
time in the fifth time and we're lazy
right the classic you know good
developers at lazy developers and they
don't want to do things too much times
we very much take that to heart
especially for operational test
something else that we think about a lot
at bit ly estate management so I did a
story around this so about a year and a
half ago when i was first interviewing a
bit ly something that came up in the
conversation will generally come up in
like a technical interview is the
question how they manage kind of there
there s am like how they managed code
code control and it came up in that
conversation that bit ly manages all
their code both systems code and
basically configuration management code
and practical purposes imagine chef and
puppet in one giant monolithic repo and
at first I was like what that sounds
insane how is that not a giant rats
nests where you can't find anything and
manage anything but we talked about it
for a bit and kind of came around to
this isn't so bad right if you have some
practice in place that in for some
disciplines so that you can basically
manage that that tendency for things to
decay into a rat's nest you get this
really powerful side effect of having a
unified view of the world of code and
config being joined any given commit in
our repository is a complete snapshot of
the state of our system menace data so
that's really powerful as far as if
you're trying to either go back in time
and figure out what things were going on
or if you need to do a rollback or bail
out of a bad deploy you don't have to go
through and figure out like okay what
like yeah I don't know how many gone
through like okay we did deploy things
are really bad we have to roll back
right the first step in that is like
okay where do we roll back to because
it's not necessarily the last commit if
you have coming from a dozen repos you
have to do that a dozen times now which
is not exciting with things are on fire
if you have everything in one repo you
can kind of just grow back and there's
some scaling at limitations of that but
a quirk we found from talking to people
was like this is actually how to a
certain degree google and facebook also
do things right like and for much of the
same reasons so you have some kind
interesting benefits there the next
really fundamental way we look at things
that has deep implications for
everything we do is service-oriented
architecture so if you look at bit ly
from a code perspective there is no one
bit ly application there are dozens of
little services that focus on particular
tasks that then tie together in
relatively loose ways to make the system
overall and this gives us a ton of nice
benefits we also cheat a little bit in
making that easier for us but I'm not
going to talk about the too much this so
one of the biggest things for us is what
failure looks like in the context of SOA
if in a monolithic application what
tends to happen is if there's some let's
say there's a bad deploy and let's say
there's some kind of configuration
problem where you can't talk to cash
something like that right your entire
system goes down hard day and that's the
way set up since you have isolation
between these different services and
very specific boundaries between them
it's extremely unlikely that you'll take
down the entire system most of the time
what will happen is you'll just have a
particular service go down and you'll
certainly have a degraded user
experience right a particular feature
won't work but the Super's overall will
keep going which is really important for
us because again not breaking the
internet another nice side effect of
this kind of setup is when we do a
deploy like one of those 20 plus 20 is a
day we're never deploying to all 400
servers at once aside from the actual
like computational tasks that's involved
which is non-trivial on that that's
potentially a very destabilizing thing
to do but since everything is broken
down into services where the specific
hardware handling different services we
only need a deploy to the servers where
the service runs
sure so the question was if we have one
big repo for all of our code but we only
want certain bits of that code running
on a and given server how do we figure
that out the practical answer to that is
while we have one big repo we organize
things within that repo that's basically
a bunch of top-level directories and
those top-level directories are
basically services so there's no cross
communication or library sharing between
those aside from through normal system
stuff so munster stuffs Python so
there's something that needs to be
shared across services like it gets
installed as a Python package through
our deploy process and that's how that
gets shared and then basically we have
it our configuration management system
is homegrown and this crazy pile of bash
and Python for practical purposes from a
high enough level you can think of it as
chef and puppet and basically have a
system of tags for the servers so kind
of like roles and chef and I imagine
puppet as something similar haven't
worked that within a much to basically
say these are the services that should
run in this particular box and based on
that able kind of start up or tear down
services accordingly it's that cool
another really powerful aspect of
service-oriented architecture is it
makes everything easier to understand
both when you're debugging and when
you're architecting systems I think you
can think of this as like functions and
classes in your code right like while
you technically could write whatever
application you're going to write is
just one giant pile of you know sara lee
executing code you'll go insane trying
to figure keep track of anything longer
than a few hundred lines right so we
have these abstractions that allow you
to isolate functionality to specific
little pieces and then either pay
attention to how the pieces fit together
or the implementation inside of one
individual piece but not having to keep
the whole picture in your head at once
similarly services give you a similar
kind of abstraction in that you can
either look at a systemic level right if
you just know stuffs broken but i'm not
sure what is actually the problem you
can look at a system level to say what
piece is likely broken then when you
figure out that piece you can kind of
invert how you're looking at those API
boundaries and just look inside that
service and see what's going on which is
we are really powerful for understanding
stuff one of the this gets takes things
a step further as your code base ages
so--but Lee's been around for about five
years there's a lot of code there and
like I've been there for a year and a
half and I still don't know all the code
right like it's just a lot but that's
okay because most of our services are
less than a few hundred lines on their
own so even if you've never touched a
service you can just dive into it and
understand it very quickly and deal with
that as you need to another nice benefit
of this setup is it makes it very easy
to use the right tool for the right job
so as I've kind of looted to our default
at bit Leah's Python just because we
like it we find it readable we can
develop into quickly but those things
that it's maybe not always the best tool
for right if you have to do really
complex concurrency that is miserable in
Python if you have to iterate over
things really quickly it's just not that
good at it so when we run into
situations where Python isn't the right
tool for the right job we can pull in
other things very easily because our
service boundaries are just kind of
platform agnostic right it's just JSON
either through HTTP calls or pub/sub
hughes so for example we need something
to be faster doing crates concurrency we
tend to use go we have a search system
where lucene is really appealing so we
use Jonathan right we can just plug
those in as we need to that has some
other potential risks as far as using
all the tools and how many figure to
keep that in your head but with some
discipline it's not so bad excuse me
similar we can use data stores as it
makes sense for a given service so part
of the isolation between systems is if
they need to persist data they each take
care of that persistence on their own so
our data is massively denormalized this
is one of the ways we can cheat and that
our data is effectively immutable since
links don't change and climate change
but there are ways to do this too for
you to have more immune Ville data but
accordingly each service can have a data
store that makes sense on its own so we
have one service that's basically a
metadata that we get from crawling pages
because doing natural pearls a fairly
expensive operation and that's basically
just a key Val
you think with billions of things right
so that kind of sounds like react so we
just use we're out there this is another
service where we kind of keep track of
real-time flick rates on and there Redis
is a really good fit because we want it
to be fast we care about like it's nice
to have those complex data structures
but the overall data sets not going to
be that big so it can fit in memory so
we're going to use the right tool for
the right job similarly we can use a
suit hardware as needed right like our
default is something that looks like a
sig 1 medium or it's the new ones see
three large on ec2 just because we've
optimized for cross performance on those
but some things need a lot of memory or
they need SSDs right so we can build
things to accommodate like that
similarly we can make decisions as far
as what data center runs in as far as
having actual hardware versus the
virtualization we can also scale
services that's needed right so let's
say we make a change that means that
we're going to be crawling twice as many
things as reprieved that you previously
used to we can just add more resources
and scale that scrolling service without
having to have anything else care about
that right since you have those
boundaries of separations of concerns
you can deal with those problems just
where they happen without having to
worry about too many consequences to
other parts of the system which again
when you're not worried about when you
have those clean isolations keeps things
stable yep
right now we have tooling for ec2 and so
are we r an easy to we have a
effectively dedicated hardware within a
bear assign data center sorry Latoya
Center we potentially could move into
other clouds but we haven't built the
torn for that just curious to get extra
context some links so from just actual
redirects that we do we get some
contacts just based on what the browser
sends is part of that redirect process
but we usually don't can't tell what the
page is about so we'll crawl a bunch of
pages and do a bunch of analysis to say
like what the topic of this page is
maybe pictures titles stuff like that
and the last thing that we get from this
is significant cost savings right by
being very being able to very
specifically Taylor hardware and
optimizations to give insist particular
services that are focused on specific
tasks we can save a ton of money because
we're not spending having a bunch of
stuff sitting around not getting used
should we can kind of tailor things as
it needs to be tailored the next thing
that we think about is a sink being
better than synchronous except when it
is this point you might think it's going
to go into some tirade about some
hipster like no Jas or whatever
thankfully we're talking at a different
level something more architectural right
when we look at building systems we try
and ask can this look more like sending
letters in the mail than two people
having a conversation right because you
get a bunch of benefits by having that
bad different relationship between
systems in particular you get better
isolation and looser coupling right so
and accordingly you get more flexibility
and a lot of that comes down to what
ever and load situations look like right
so let's say you know our metric system
that's keeping track of like our time
series database that keeps track of how
many clicks something has gotten
negative in time period so that's having
some kind of pass the issue
and it can't keep track of just the
stream of data coming at it if you're
dealing with some kind of synchronous
process now suddenly that capacity issue
or that failure is a problem for the
upstream system that's handling the
redirects that's producing the data for
that system but if you have things going
through something that's more
asynchronous and particular something
with queues the upstream system doesn't
need a care right it can keep
advertising that that things have
happened and the downs then that can
just pile up for a while while the
downstream system works through whatever
needs two and then can just work through
that backlog as it needs to the got you
hear that situation of except when it
isn't is when you care a lot about
consistency so kind to give you a
practical example when you shorten a
link on bit ly everything that happens
there at a systemic level is completely
synchronous right so that goes through a
bunch of layers of our architecture and
that's all either HTTP basically
blocking HTTP calls or blocking database
calls and the reason for that is we care
a ton about consistency here right
because we can't give the same bit ly
hash to two different long URLs because
that's kind of like crossing the streams
right like just that doesn't work the
universe kind of end and similarly we
much prefer to say hey we had a problem
we couldn't give you a bit ly length
than to give you a bitly link that
doesn't work you technically could do
that in an asynchronous way but keeping
track of all those failure scenarios
gets much more complicated and doing
that in a timely manner gets much more
complicated we care about this being
very fast on the other hand for metrics
incrementing if where's a few seconds or
maybe even a minute of delay and
updating our status pages but on the
other hand we care about redirecting
users really quickly right so we don't
know if there's some problem with our
metric system we don't want to have the
redirects get slowed down or broken
right our metric system failing should
never be the reason that redirects don't
work so by pushing making that an
asynchronous process it makes it very
easy to get that isolation and that kind
of loose coupling between there one of
the other things that can be nice kind
of related to loose coupling is when you
have things be asynchronous it's very
it's much easier to kind of kind of tee
off those streams to make copies of them
which I'll get into a bit so the way we
actually go about doing a lot of this
asynchronous stuff at architectural
level is a system called n SQ it's an
open source distributed messaging
platform that we've built an open
released you might be looking at me and
hearing distribute real-time messaging
what on earth does that actually mean
I'm not going to go super deep into it
but we can go through some features so n
SQ uses pub/sub messaging semantics you
mess you publish messages to a topic
then you have can have channels but you
can kind of think it was like copies of
that topic for given purpose which then
have a set of consumers it's distributed
so there's no single point of failure
and there's no central bottlenecks I
don't need to worry about having your am
PQ server fill up and we fall over
because it's out of memory or a sad of
erling processes similarly you don't
have to worry about like the physical
Nick card on a given box getting
saturated you have some other couch
isn't that like there's no strong
ordering but punching to use case the
other thing that's nice here is there's
dynamic configuration so if you're going
to add new channels or topics that all
happens at runtime you don't have to
worry about doing complicated ordered
deploys to manage that and as name kind
of suggests there are queuing of
messages so in addition to those pub/sub
semester semantics as if kind of alluded
to if the consumers can't keep up with
the publishers it'll kind of just back
up for a while and you can set like high
watermarks well go from memory onto disk
so that your servers and falling over
because you used all the memory which
we've seen him then can be entertaining
but unfortunate and it also can have at
least once deliberate guarantees there's
a few different kind of architectures
that you can do with NS q it's kind of
like a set of tools and there's
different ways you can use it but you
can use in a way swear you have at least
once guarantees people sometimes ask
about only once guarantees and that's
kind of a distributed system problem
that's not possible if you're interested
we can talk later if you're interested
in SQ you can go check it out on github
there's some pretty solid documentation
is actually a pretty decent community of
people using it in addition to us and if
or want to talk about more talk to me
afterwards I'll hang out for a while the
next thing that we think about when we
think about how do we keep moving fast
without breaking stuff is user
interfaces user interfaces provide a few
things right they make things
discoverable and they make things
accessible and they give you the right
info at the right time so here's some
examples of that we have something
internally called deploy you I we would
open source it but it's so specific to
our weirdo deployment system that
doesn't make sense it's really a thin
wrapper around our deployment system but
it illustrates a lot of this stuff
nicely right for developers who aren't
necessarily you know heads deep in ops
world it makes it very easy for them to
push out code in a relatively safe way
yeah you can just hear say awesome you
can say what service you want to deploy
to what code you want to push their
right here you can just say like I want
this branch for this user and will
auto-populate you can pull requests and
give a comment about why you're doing it
because we need to deploy and things
break can be you guys to have that extra
context and then also kind of give you a
recent history about deploys again is
nice if you're on call and suddenly get
a thousand nagios alerts saying hey the
world's broken if somebody just did a
deploy might be related similarly if
you're about to go do a deploy you see
somebody's doing the flow to the servers
that your nipple you want to deploy to
you should go probably go talk to that
person cuz you might step on each
other's toes so just a lot of again my
information that my time and make it
easy for people to do things another
thing that's a really big you I've for
us is fabric I imagine most people in
this audience are familiar with it if
not you can kind of think of it is bash
over ssh with a bit of Python mixed in
basically it's a very easy command-line
interface for managing a bunch of stuff
remotely in a procedural way so that
this deploy UI is actually just a thin
wrapper on top of the deploy command
within our fabric setup there's a bunch
of other common operational tasks that
you can do through fabric as far as like
taking stuff out of the low balance or
whatnot this is how you can think of
this as affordance different people want
to work in different ways so pick some
people do deploys the UI some people do
through fabric just make sense for
different people n SQ has a very nice
avin that is also open source again you
can kind of think of the right info at
the right time so this is looking at the
page for a topic so you can see what
servers are producing given topic you
can kind of see some stuff out of
graphite as far as Hugh deaths and stuff
like that pretty much of an these lines
are going up into the right something's
probably broken and you can drill down
into the channels again you can see at
individual consumers and you can have
the right context on whether or not
something's broken or if something is
broken where specifically the problem is
and you can do some operational tests in
here which are convenient right so let's
say you're killing a system nobody's
going to consume you this topic anymore
and kill those servers delete the topic
through here on the channel screen you
can also do stuff like pause channels so
let's say you're going to do some kind
of database maintenance where you be
nice to not have any rights going on you
can just pause a channel be confident
all the rights going into that system or
not getting dropped but not going into
the system do your maintenance and then
resume the channel and the world is good
again right information right time tools
and making it's easier to use we use the
github status API commit status API so
like I said for all all open pull
requests we have Jenkins does a build
and when it does that build it reports
it back into github so when you're
looking at that pull request in a code
review you can see oh hey Jenkins says
your stuff is broken fix that right so
this goes a long way to helping us not
merge broken code and it makes it really
easy for us to be lazy right nobody
wants to have to like when they're doing
the code review remember to go over to
jump in and see if the build worked then
come back right this way they can just
see is it green or not it's great sorry
styling the bits there something else we
did recently so as imagine a bunch of
you have either seen or even dealt with
there's been somebody going around
giving some extortion threats and
doing denial of service attacks we got
some of those so we have a bunch of
disaster recovery plans one of the
things we learned in that process is
that when it's four o'clock in the
morning and you're Bragi and you just
got page saying the world's broken you
might take you a while to figure out
where all the stuff is to engage the
disaster recovery plans so we built
something called the red button at you I
this makes it really easy to a wake up
the rest of the ops team to help out and
then be engaged the disaster recovery
plan yeah making things easy and this is
something that one of our engineers
built in like two or three days right
using the tools that we already had so
it doesn't get be anything crazy or
complicated but especially if you go
down the path of automating as much as
you can it makes it really easy to build
these things as you need them the next
big piece of how we do things is peer
review like I mentioned we use github
pretty heavily and a lot of process
around this is kind of interesting in
that this is one of those places where
you can run to the danger getting into
this really draconian heavy-handed like
heavy process stuff but we have just one
rule that everything else falls out from
as a side effect it's only one formal
rule and that is if you wrote the code
you are not allowed to hit that green
button right so this has a bunch of
wonderful side effects my favorite of
which is it moves the worst problems
that you have around this kind of stuff
to better places right when it's the end
of the day and somebody push our change
the broke and you just need to push out
a one line change to fix it yep
potentially so it depends on what's
going on it's I mean we definitely do
have the attitude of while we have an
on-call rotation which is a fixed set of
people if your code breaks you're
getting a phone call potentially we are
I get kind of where I was going with
that is culturally for us it's very ok
to wake up other people if you need to
the other side is for certain scales of
changes it's okay to push out code that
hasn't been merged yet a lot of times
we'll soak code in production as far
more validation steps before it gets
merged the idea here is that master
should always be safe right so if we a
lot of times most of the time the answer
when somebody does get paged in the
morning it's not a code change it's a
rollback right and part of how we can do
that a four o'clock in the morning
without somebody else there is trusting
that master is safe this is our part we
guarantee that but in the case where
there are other people around and we do
have that one lane change to fix stuff
that you probably have a type of win
because there's always wanted a one line
change this moves us to a better place
is instead of pushing it out and making
stuff worse your problem now is to find
somebody in the office tap them on the
shoulder say look at this they'll find
the typos you'll fix it and then you
push it out right it makes it a better
situation something that you might have
noticed is the title slide for this
section was peer review and not code
review and the reason for that is we the
scope for the review is wire than just
the code will take a lot of operational
and architectural concerns as part of
that review so a lot of times what we'll
do I mean obviously it depends on the
scale the change some changes are just
minor code changes don't have any
approach you'll change involved awesome
great easy when let's say you're
launching a new system well they
enumerate any kind of operational tasks
that are involved in having that system
go out as checklists as part of the code
and when somebody's revealing in that
code they are signing off both on the
process that's
as well as the code itself this is saved
us a ton of headaches and time kind of
examples that is any time we're rolling
out something actually has some kind of
order like the porter dependencies this
is really good for flushing that I'm
sure yes yeah no I mean that's something
yeah I don't highlight very well here I
guess explicitly but we are very much of
the attitude that ideally deploys should
be non-events right i deploy should be
as small as possible therefore they're
going to least likely things therefore
they're not scary right there's some
more stuff we do come in that vein but
yes everybody has the ability to employ
pretty much right away we do some
permission around in that deploy you I
you basically we do have some permission
and controls about what service people
can deploy to but we are fairly liberal
about opening it up as people need so
it's more a making sure you can't make
easy accidents as opposed to preventing
people from doing stuff generally our
attitudes things should be as
self-service as possible this also gets
to our next point is since all these
code reviews and this is a little bit of
cheating rotor size right so bit ly
overalls about a 50-person company of
that's about 20 engineers so enough
people where if you go on vacation it's
not a problem but you know big enough
where you know everybody and you can
track them roughly what everybody's
doing but since these pull requests are
open to everybody they're also a really
good mechanism for cross-team share most
of the time as something's going out
especially if it has offs implications
if somebody on my team cut the
application engineering kind of thing of
back in the business logic most of the
time somebody from off school at least
look over it and make sure there's no
like oh hey hey that's going to cause
problems let's talk about that right
like so yep
ah we don't really make that distinction
right so so the way we handle that is we
have what we call our office
infrastructure team so they they're the
owners of traditional ops like keep the
server's up kind of stuff but they also
responsible for like n SQ and I'm a lot
of our database stuff and even some kind
of internal joint stuff and our bias is
very much towards hiring engineers who
could system and stuff than the other
way around so for us it's not like we
very much try and avoid situations where
we're in the mindset of where we're
throwing over the wall right it's
very much a share of responsibility kind
of attitude which does actually get to
the next bit of how we approach things
as far as how we handle architecture and
planning this is another place where you
can very easily get into a place where
you get very draconian and very things
feel heavy it's hard to do stuff but we
try and keep what we're trying to remain
diligent while keeping to lightweight
and the way we do that is basically by
asking a series of questions yeah
there's no like binder of questions
right like I'm literally going to go
through the questions we ask and this is
often for takes the form of like some
ops people and some other people who are
involved in the project sitting in front
of a white board and having a
conversation like this is like an
hour-long exercise it's not huge the
first thing that we usually ask is how
is this going to be backwards compatible
right if there are any kind of both pup
well public facing API changes are a
whole other beast largely in that you
can't do them least breaking changes at
least not easily something we've learned
over the years if you publish an API
people will make calls matching that API
until the end of time how much you care
about maybe a different question but
they will make those calls anyway
internally everything has to be
backwards compatible and the main reason
for that is deploys aren't instant right
just as a practical reality if you're
deploying to a cluster of two dozen
servers it's not going to happen at once
you're going to have at least two
versions of code
existing in production at the same time
those have to be able to play nice with
each other and most of time making that
backwards compatible ability work isn't
too bad it's just one of the things you
have to think of up front similarly
having that backwards compatibility in
place makes rollouts and roll backs and
bail out so much easier right if things
are backwards compatible with how they
were just making everything back to how
it was it's probably fine the next thing
is we think about is how are we going to
do this without downtime there may have
been one or two small exceptions at some
point in its history but at this point
for us outages for system updates or not
okay excuse me willing to do a fair
amount of work to make sure that we can
do it you know makes whatever change we
need to make without downtime but most
of the time it's actually not as bad as
it seems especially when you have that
SOA kind of setup and especially if this
is the interfaces between the systems
you're dealing with are those
asynchronous queues everything gets much
easier an example here is we have this
like user his system that's based on
this sharded set up and it
basically wasn't going to scale as it
was set up so what we were able to do is
stand up a new cluster copy have the
rights get copied so we're dual riding
into both systems and that's easy to do
with ms q move data over from the old
system to the new one from before the
time we started you'll writing and then
once that's done just move over the
reads as we want right so that's when we
had no downtime even know right outage
we completely moved from one physical
cluster to another and is completely
transparent to users and it wasn't that
like it was more work certainly but it
wasn't that much more work for us and
again it's one of the things for when
you asked that question up front like
building the system then go realizing oh
wow this is going to cause us trouble
how we deal with it right the next thing
that comes up and this is where a lot of
just kind of different
of different people and different teams
comes in it's asking how are we going to
know something broken right what
monitoring does this need what you know
what now gives checks does this need
what stash should be collected hey if it
breaks am I going to get page if I get
page how am I going to know what to do
all that gets asked upfront and to beat
a dead horse when you ask that up front
it's much easier to deal with then when
you're about to deploy the system and
then somebody goes hey so that cron job
doesn't run what happens right partially
so usually from a systemic level that
conversation happens before there's even
any code written so there'll be a high
level thing of like okay well we know
we're going to have this database
involved we're gonna have these
processes involves and they'll have to
be this thing happened periodically so
will develop basically as part of the
requirements for the system know that
we'll have to have checks here here and
there but then potentially the main
place where that checklist gets involved
is let's say so actually in the case of
that system switchover I was
talking about what that checklist would
have consisted of would be the steps of
like okay so we're going to bring up the
new system we're going to start doing
writes into that system we're going to
do that whatever steps we need to copy
over the data and then we're going to
switch reads and then we're going to do
this to get confidence that the reads
are work we're like everything's working
right and then we'll kill the old system
like that's what we'll be in that
checklist so
for the most part i mean there's
different levels like that that one's
pretty involved a lot of times what
we'll do what the checklist for the
smaller stuff will consist of is what
the validation steps are right so there
are ways things can break which won't
necessarily set off checks right like if
some CSS is kind of at least with our
current testing that's probably not
going to set up an alert but it'll piss
off the user so we define what those
checks will plug I'll get to that it
actually this touches a little bit on
I'll get into a bit more now but so kind
of continuing on that once we know
something's broken what do we have to
have in place to figure out what's wrong
right what needs to be logged what needs
where's that log going and what has to
go into our stats system Brian s able
use graphite a lot I forget the exact
number but we're in the billions if not
tens of billions of increments a day for
a graphite cluster so yeah again when i
get that page at four o'clock in the
morning and i skid alert saying hey this
thing's broken what's the next step how
do i figure out where to go next what
operational options are there for
dealing with failures right so different
systems are going to look different ways
when they fall down or when systems they
care about go down right so let's say a
box for a particular service goes down
does that mean that we need to pause
cues so we don't lose data while we
handle reprovision in the box or is a
particular class of machine stateless if
we just spit up a new box right like
what what what are those failure
scenarios look like and how do we deal
with that and where do I find that
information is kind of questions up with
that next question is how available does
assistant need to be one of the other
nice things about an SOA type system is
we can have different availability
guarantees for different services so as
an example our decode
service has massive redundancy built
into it we're at the place where even if
our primary data center literally falls
off the face of the planet we could be
up and redirecting within a few minutes
right on the other hand some of our
reefs like our Hadoop cluster which is
primarily used for research has at this
point if it goes down for an hour it's
not awesome some people are going to be
kind of annoyed internally but not the
end of the world we don't need to spend
more resources making that more
available so we kind of have a
conversation about kind of cost benefits
both in times of literal costs of actual
hardware as well as like dev time and
attention and then I guess I kind of had
that we're not late anyway again paid a
lot attention to failure scenarios
because that's where stuff get squirrely
oh sorry this is speaking to how failure
of other system is going to deal with it
how can we Brown around failure right so
this is query another system and one of
the boxes in that system goes weird what
impact is that going to happen how do we
deal with that one of the ways we deal
with that is we have a library called
host pool it's open source this one's
Python somewhere we have a go one I
forgot the link is can probably find it
the idea there is you can kind of think
of it and in application load balancer
in the sense of the way it works is
you'll say instead of saying this is the
just URL I want to query for the other
system you can say that this is the pool
of servers I want a query first so when
you do a query you ask for a server to
query you do it you do your query and
then when you get the response you
either say that worked or it didn't and
the library then kind of in-memory just
keeps track of those success rates and
then increases the probability that
healthy servers will get queried
effectively allows things to self heal
and self route around failures obviously
you want to have ma during in place to
know when that happens because
self-healing you only go so far and
having Brooklyn stuff out there is not
great long-term but it helps you know
deal with stuff while you're figuring
while the slow humans are figuring out
what's going on similarly n SQ has a lot
of capacity for routing around failure
but again if you're interested I can
talk about later
what hardware will this require again
kind of going back to the SOA discussion
can this be okay on the scene 1 medium
or do we need SSDs do we need more
memory what do we need here and
similarly is what this is going to be
doing going to justify the cost
associated with that what have discussed
at least have an understanding of what's
involved in adding capacity a lot of
times we'll build systems to that you
know for the next six months we'll be
fine but what's going to happen if
either we get more traffic than we
expected before those six months go up
right sometimes it can be nice and like
if it's just a nice stateless service
it's the answer is tor more hardware at
it awesome great throwing money at the
problems is always a fantastic answer
but other times it's harder right like
if you have just my single database
throwing hard we're at it is kind of not
easy to do right so what does that
process look like and if not having the
tooling in place right now understanding
and documenting what the avenues are for
a given system it's important for us
again similarly there's often when we're
building new services asking these
questions up front allow us to make
relatively easy to make changes from an
architectural standpoint that when asked
at the beginning make things down the
road much easier but if you did later in
the process what involve like stuff
right we also since we run into data
centers we have the question of what
data center should this run it there's a
certain amount of there's some
situations where cost performance is
better for the physical hardware than
the virtual in particular RAM and disk
space a lot better for the fiscal for us
for CPU bound stuff it's kind of saying
actually the bigger thing for us often
is understanding what other services
this is going to be chatting with so if
there's another services that this thing
is going with this new service is going
to be chatting with it'll probably be
nice to not have that chinesse going
over public networks and just staying on
a land so a lot of times we'll try and
co-locate services that rely on each
other a lot similarly what kind of
relatedly what we ask what impact a new
service is going to have another systems
right if
he's going to be increasing the load on
the system x 10 x no this is probably
gonna care about that right so we have
to work for the implications of that
again most the time not too bad if we
ask it up front but if you didn't ask
the question wash it and all the sudden
that system has 10x load that's probably
not going to be an awesome day and the
last question we try and ask is will
there be any ongoing operational tasks
obviously we try and build systems so
that they more or less they carry
themselves but sometimes especially for
the first one or two iterations of a
system it makes sense you just have an
off test happen every six months right
we have a system that like archives the
raw data that will crawl off the
internet and it turns out doing out
expiration of billions of things is
really really hard computationally and
the easiest solution we found is just
have those that like crawl cash off a
bunch of EBS mounts and every couple
months just format one of those mounts
and call it done right like it's just
there and we just at this point like
it's a rare enough thing that's easy
enough that it just hasn't made sense to
build the tooling for but we want to
understand that make sure we're doing
that cost trade-off equation of do we
need to build a tooling to automate this
or can it just be an operational test
for now I'll banyak to the gentleman's
question monitoring the scary stuff
that's going to wake us up in the middle
of the night so for learning we use
nagios it is bizarre it is Byzantine it
literally takes you eight months to
figure out where an earth stuff is in
the interface but it is solid as a rock
and once you damage your brain to
understand it it's fine at least for us
like we have enough grizzled graybeard
ops people that they knew this off the
bat it was the easy answer for us if
it's not now go so you need something
that when something breaks will notice
and wake you up because I forget who
attributed this soup but there's a great
coat of if you don't have a nagios check
on something it is probably broken you
just don't know about it yet if you're
not actively checking things and making
sure they're doing what you think they
are doing it's almost certainly broken
in some way so they actually that's
interesting that we've done starting to
do more aggressive recently is in
addition to doing kind of the obvious
nagios share some is
of stuff up our super metrics within
normal bounds right we're not swapping
out or whatever we've actually started
adding data integrity checks in to
nagios as well we've actually learned
two situations where services will be up
and look like they're operating right
but be telling you dirty filthy lies
when you ask them things and that's
obviously not great so we add an eye
goes checks to make sure that's not
happening so I'm gonna think about
graphite again we're at etsy thank you
we use this a ton pretty much anything
that we care about in aggregate we we
add metric tonne a lot of times we even
just instrument stuff and graphite just
because it might be interesting we
actually spend a decent money on our
graphic cluster but we throw a lot at it
I and then we also are then able to pull
that data into other things very easily
so this is example poured that's
basically just a health of our API right
it's just kind of stuff you would expect
right unknown errors per minute 99
percent times ninety-five percent times
if you look down the mean times and
there again if any those are going up
into the right or if there's a big spike
in there somewhere you probably want to
look at it because stuffs broke this is
actually the kind of stuff that we're
starting to work on adding physical just
like dashboards and like TVs into our
office so you have that awareness of
like how hey you just go to your coffee
and go oh hey there's a big spike 10
minutes ago in our main response time
what's that about you know digging into
that centralized searchable logs are
really powerful right now we have a
ghetto wrapper on rap hopefully soon
we'll be switching to log stash and
Cabana basically like an open-source
slunk but that's where we are today
under the covers syslog getting
everything to one place but having
everything like all your public requests
into bit ly go into a cluster of two
dozen servers if one of them is having
errors fearing out which one of them is
going to take some time if you have to
log in to eat to them individually
having it logs in one central place
where you can search things is pretty
powerful
and to wrap things up some quick fun
with us be deliberate make sure your
you're doing things for a specific
reason and not just throwing show at the
wall kind of the same vein understand
why you're doing something like it's
really easy to just look up the yeah the
random searches on flickr for Creative
Commons stuff is fantastic if you it's
really easy to like have a problem do
the stack overflow search and find a
solution but not take that extra step to
understand why that solution addresses
your problem take that extra step it
really pays off big big time it's only
worth of the details and obviously there
are limits on all this if you take this
to an extreme you'll just be digging
into like how your your specific
compiler and processor working and
that's probably not productive most of
the time but maybe go a layer or two
deeper than you absolutely have to
understand what's going on it really
both helps further you as a developer
and make sure that you were doing what
you actually need to be doing and
finally a quick shameless plug bit ly
shockingly for hiring we really want to
talk to you we'd love to talk to you
come talk to me afterwards or check it
out but lecom slash jobs and if that any
questions
logstash and cabana so log stash you can
kind of think is like a thing that
routes streams of logs and makes it easy
to push up into elasticsearch and Cabana
is like a UI on top of elastic surfaces
optimized for logs we've had some courts
implementing it but that's more quirks
of our obstruction those particular
tools yes
sure um sorry I've been doing a bad job
as I should be repaying the questions so
the question is obviously bit ly hasn't
always been doing this how do we get
here and if there's been a particular
critical moments in that path Oh for
better or worse actually a lot of this
was already in place when i joined bit
ly at least from a high level a lot of
it has been a matter of having a culture
of caring about process but also having
an analogy to enterprise eNOS right and
that definitely creates tension right
there a lot of times when something goes
wrong there's a very easy answer of
developing a process to not do that
again right but if you do that all the
time and take that easy answer you end
up with this like that's how you end up
with like the crazy like you know
enterprising world type stuff right so a
lot of it basically comes down to caring
about process like and thinking about
things in those terms being willing to
take the time to figure out if there is
a using this word but more elegant
solution than just making process to not
do that again and doing things they are
deeply something else that's kind of
interesting of this for especially like
lean type folks it wasn't I don't think
done in quite that intentional of a way
but just intuitively as the way we work
virtually none of this was done like as
a fundamental change in by Fiat a lot of
it has just been kind of incrementally
done as needed overtime as the team's
grown I don't that it's usually
cool I think there was a question in the
back
uh so this is again a place where I
suspect we're cheating by our size right
now there's just one on-call rotation
and whoever's on call guess the alerts
period we have sorry to talk and think
about potentially having more directed
ownership like that but we haven't gone
there yet and for the most part
thankfully it's relatively rare that new
systems break at four o'clock in the
morning I guess via the rest of our
process and doing stuff like doing
partial the like especially for back-end
systems a lot of times part of our
validation process like let's say I'm
rolling out a change how a particular
like user-facing API is implemented that
doesn't have any functional changes to
the user but changes how we do things
internally a lot of times we'll just
deploy that to one or two servers let it
soak for a day and then push it out like
doing stuff like that makes it pretty
rare that new systems cause problems at
four o'clock good morning
ah yes thank you so the question is how
we're actually deploying how to describe
it so like I said it's a homegrown
system that when you kind of squint hard
enough and look at a high enough level
abstraction looks a lot like chef and
puppet the particularly interesting way
that's the case is there's basically a
series of tags that define what a series
should be which then run a series of
item potent install scripts that will
basically like the the tags will
basically say like so the process that
does redirects for us is called an SD
right so we'll have a tag that says NSD
should be running on this box and should
have like n like four copies of that
process running right so the install
script will basically go through and say
like ok is the version that I expect
installed in the box yes great i'll just
move on in not care no ok let me do what
I ever I gotta do to get the Box closer
to the desired state I that level is
pretty standard how I actually go about
implementing it it's basically a giant
pile of ash with some tools to make it
easier to do the item potent stuff and
most of the time we try and work with
whatever environments toolchain the
Python stuff is a little non-standard
but that's mostly just because like a
lot of wide this stuff is homegrown is
not because the existing tools are
inadequate it's just they didn't exist
when the stuff was built and like the
migrating cost is not justified but yeah
we lot of our binary stuff gets
installed by rpm we're running centos 5
something in most places a lot of stuff
we just run our own binaries for but a
lot of high thought stuff gets a fairly
standard
sorry yep
we years neither I just use those
examples and that that that approach of
basically having something that defines
what a server should be and then having
a series of idempotent scripts to get it
closer to that state is roughly
architectural what our system looks like
the actual implementation that is just
hope so to paraphrase the question how
do we manage complexity and SOA on the
system side we get to cheat a ton
because our data is effective the line
share of our data is idempotent
immutable right so the fact that we
don't have to deal with changes or
deletes makes a whole lot of problems
way easier right because denormalization
at that point is dumb simple right like
you just get a copy of all the rights
that happened and you're done it's easy
it's great so there are a lot of things
where we just don't have that problem
which is somewhat cheating on our part
or just not cheating but taking
advantage of the situation we're in it
definitely is more complicated situation
for other people we do run into some of
that as far as joining datasets right so
actually a lot of the quirks in the
existing bit ly interface as far as like
well why can't I just filter my links by
this that and the other thing the answer
is because that's in five different
systems and doing joins across databases
is not a thing and so the answer there
is usually if we have to do a new kind
of combination of data that means a new
service as far as managing complexity
from a tooling standpoint it's a lot of
basically self-discipline there
definitely was a phase of bit ly where
we had a database of the week problem at
this point we basically have all the
open source databases except for
postgres and even now that we have
redshift we have a weirdo flavor of that
but releasing the time that I've been
there we've done pretty good about
effectively if somebody proposes using a
new data store or a new language or no
platform asking the hard questions is
justified right so and actually that's
one thing they're really like about bit
ly is there the culture is very much in
a place where making those proposals is
totally okay but you better be able to
justify your position right if you want
to bring in a new database you better be
able to damn well explain why one ones
that we already have a bunch of
experience and chilling in place are
inadequate
similar if you want to bring in a new
language apply for me you have to be
able to answer those kinds of questions
we've also started at least for
databases I don't think we intentionally
did it but it's kind of happened if you
bring it in your database you're on the
old confrontation so that also kind of
helps keep people using what's there but
yeah it definitely is a struggle that's
something we have to work with sorry
I'll get the side of then
you
yep
uh so we're lazy and we have an
unbelievable java / JVM allergy a bit ly
sorry the question was how do we
actually handle gain the commit status
stuff back our Jenkins so we have this
bordering on irrational JVM algae a bit
ly I love it comes down to just getting
burned a few times in the past than not
being lacing that one have to learn how
to do JB I'm tuning because we don't
have experience in that accordingly for
certain styles of that workflow there
are plugins for Jenkins that'll just do
it we ran into some quirks and that
since we do so made like we try and keep
our pull request small accordingly I
think we're up to issue number okay
we're in like the 25 hundreds on github
and I just as a quirk is gig as github
implements ways to actually pull down
that bull request code it breaks a lot
of existing plugins so we basically have
a sidecar service that uses the github
commit hook API and then Jenkins has a
similar thing where you can subscribe to
notifications about things that have
been decided Jenkins now basically
handling the messages back and forth you
entirely could implement it as a Jenkins
plugin but we're hate Java so I think
there's a question over here
yes
I
sure
yep so there's some interesting there's
the question to repeat it was basically
what is our staging environment we look
like and what it transitions from
devastating a proud look like so we have
some interesting quirks in there the
most prominent of which is for us
staging is generally staging of code not
of data so our staging environment
actually queries production databases
and production back-end systems in a lot
of cases a lot of the reason for that is
to basically deal with the SOA
complexity issue one of the drawbacks of
an SOA setup is it's unbelievably
difficult to have a consistent subset of
data across your entire system right
because since your data is split in two
let's call it three dozen services they
each have their own snapshot of slice of
the data that the system overall has
therefore getting a consistent slice of
that to have a subset of that
infrastructure force it full on like
normal staging environment is extremely
difficult and running a mirror set up
since we see like I said I think that
works out to about 3,000 decodes per
second I was like a normal stream like
having the staging system that can
handle that is basically doubling our
servers and we just can't afford that
right now so we have the quirk of that
weird staging is just code not data most
the time it works out okay our dev
environments are we just use VMs so we
actually use the same deployment
infrastructure all the way from dev up
to production we try and keep our dev
and staging environments as close to
production as possible obviously with
the exception of actual like network
separation kind of issues and hardware
capacity and the way the promotion
process works is basically developers
would work on the local vm get it to a
place where they think excuse me it's
useful push that up to github nelsa
running in Jenkins Jenkins runs against
effectively Deb environments
then we have we use HipChat internally
so we have a hip chatbot I think it's
based off my cubot where you can reserve
staging if you need to you can push your
code there we do we have started to
we've gotten to a size where we start to
run into some issues aren't staging
contention so we're probably have to
figure out a different approach for that
soon we're not we're still working
through what that's going to look like
for front-end code there is still some
manual testing we don't have any formal
Qi people some of us by design some of
that we're desperately trying to hire
people the design part is we're fairly
against the idea of having humans who
their specific job is to just go and
click on things that's just both if we
want to do as many deploys as we want to
do that's too slow too inconsistent and
just people wise like those with
salaries that can go elsewhere so we
really focus on automation of testing so
we're really trying to hire basically a
lead QA engineer to help build out that
in production to be better than it is
particularly around front-end code right
now our front-end testing is not where
it needs to be but there accordingly the
to deal with that the lot of times when
a code change goes out that affects
front end stuff the developer as well as
other people on the team they'll say
like hey it goes up on stage and go
check it out we'll do some manual
testing that goes live but most of us
relying on automated testing
it depends I mean so a lot of those
pushes our might be operational stuff
and might be back end stuff those don't
have to deal with the manual testing
uh yeah so the question is basically who
tests the testers how do we have
confidence in the test the automated
testing infrastructure right now we
don't rely too much on cobra coverage
metrics it's basically a manual part of
the peer review process so the review
absolutely includes tests and a fair
portion time at least the reviews i do
or like hey Sol tests about those or
like AB see if there are tests in the
pull request already having questions
about like how is discovering things is
focused enough does it broadly handle
stuff one of the things that we're still
struggling a bit with that again makes
it kind of hard in the SOS environment
is kind of integration versus unit tests
and the value of each of those so we're
still kind of working through some
getting more consistent about some of
that but mostly it's the peer review
process and culture and Shane if you
have something that doesn't have test
and you get Shane curious you mentioned
like operational changes changes
um I guess this might be a case of bit
ly vocabulary leaking out to the outside
world so the question was I've been
talking about operational changes versus
co changes and what does that mean so I
apologize for that internal vocabulary
leaking not that it's precious or
anything it just doesn't mean anything
to anybody else it's mostly the intent
of the purpose of a change I guess
that's where that cut ends up falling
out sure so we'll examples of that I
guess the law comes down to who on what
teams are doing stuff and why they're
doing it so example would be a change we
made recently is so the authoritative
database of what a short length to a
long URL and vice versa is basically
this big chart of my sequel cluster
doing application level sharding and
that cluster started to run out of space
happens after five years so we had a
growth at and when you're growing
charting that usually is not trivial so
there was significant coaches involved
to grow that cluster that was largely
viewed as something the ops same for
sure shooting was owning and so on that
might be a case of why I was talking
about they're okay with somebody
originally
effectively it's always the latter the
group might happen to consist of one
server but we almost I'm sure there's
some exit exceptions somewhere that's
happened but if somebody were to ssh
onto a server and change the code
locally they would be shamed to oblivion
net bit ly like that's just not a thing
everything happens through SCM
everything happens to get everything
happens to the deploy process a lot of
that has to do with that kind of joint
state stuff of having to have that
history and have that assistant view of
the world a lot of it also has to do
with like we really rely on that
documentation right like being able to
go back and see when things were changed
is like if I went onto a server room
found code that didn't match the gate
commit that's checked out there like
there's a deep issue and whoever did
that is having like we're having a
conversation right like that's just how
we do stuff and a lot of it comes down
to when you have so many people touching
so many different pieces of a system if
you can't go back and have that
basically audit trail like things become
unmanageable very quickly yes that's our
current form of judgment
the peer review with the button rule by
far that is my my favorite thing about
how we do things a bit ly and the thing
that really enables a lot of the other
stuff whoever wrote the code is not
allowed to merge the code so everything
happens through pull requests and I mean
everything nobody makes commits to the
master unless we like somebody literally
broke it and we're fixing it which has
happened maybe twice and for us there's
a lot of ways where we're able to avoid
process through discipline and that
process is the mechanism for having
institutional discipline and that makes
sense I think there was a question over
here quick
that's an interesting question the
question was how do we decide on a
feature in an existing service versus
filling a new service a lot of it for us
comes down to how data needs to be
persisted in how it needs to be query
when you get to the scale bit ly for a
lot of things the only way to have
reasonable user queries is to pre
aggregate things so that's what a lot of
our systems are doing doing various
forms of pre aggregations like basically
like for your cliq count bit late we're
not doing select count star because that
database would have hundreds of billions
of things in at this point and that's
not a query that's going to happen in a
request response cycle at least an a
user for us so in accordingly we kind of
incremental its come in and then we just
tell you what the counter size so a lot
of it comes down to yeah basically
equation of like just as fit within a
persistence in a query model that an
existing system has and make sense in
that realm of roles and responsibilities
and if not then it means a new service
and new services are not uncommon or a
high barrier for us we probably create a
few everyone well not every month
permission once I i know i keep on going
on Oh forgets how many kind time when
I'm I'm happy to keep going but sure
okay see so you have a solid process
well for you so based on what's working
and what's not what's next is just
instrumental things like better you
should we did the best thing or are
there big things that you want yeah
that's interesting question I guess with
an ops focus one of the biggest things
for us is that stage and condition issue
we actually are starting to run
situations where devs are sitting around
twiddling their thumbs from our
acceptable periods of time waiting for
station to become available so we're
really sorry to try and work through
that we have some capacity issues just
systems that were built a while ago that
were you know intentionally designed
with certain limitations that were
running so I can run up against so we
just have to make changes to deal with
that we've mostly worked through with
the current issues with it but the dee
da stuff has been really big for the
last s actually since January we've been
dealing with the number of DDoS attacks
and getting that process down huh we've
actually been talking to some other
people who have been getting hit yeah
it's tough yeah if anybody interesting
talk about some of that stuff I'd be
happy to talk about that afterwards but
uh yeah it sucks just it's all there is
another question awesome cool you all be
great thank you